[Music]
we're talking about cars
out here honestly we don't have time for
this political nonsense
yeah liz wants to buy a buick
[Laughter]
in europe hey you me both man
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
tonight on politics now president donald
trump has the coronavirus
the political and health impact of we're
in black
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
tonight on politics now president donald
trump has the coronavirus
the political and health impact of that
diagnosis
today is only the first step in getting
back to our new normal
nevada is slowly opening up we have the
new rules for how many people can be at
large events
the main issue is that for latinos is
one to how to
pay the bills how to put food on the
table and we take a look at the role
nevada latinos will play in deciding the
next president of the united states
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler and we
start with the major news out of
washington d.c
president donald trump and first lady
melania trump have tested positive for
covet 19.
both are now in quarantine a visit to
las vegas next week
now not expected to happen so on friday
president trump announced the positive
test
posting this on twitter we will begin
our quarantine and recovery process
immediately he says we will get through
this together unquote
the announcement came hours after
president trump confirmed to fox news
one of his closest aides hope hicks
tested positive for the coronavirus she
tested
positive then i just went out with a
test i'll see what you know because we
spent a lot of time in the first lady
just went out with a test also
so whether we quarantine or whether we
have it i don't know
hicks traveled to several events with
president president trump this week
including the debate on tuesday
and his rally in minnesota on wednesday
republican national committee chairwoman
rona mcdaniel
also tested positive for the coronavirus
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden sent his well wishes to president
trump and the first lady
the pair were of course on the debate
stage together on tuesday
they both tested positive negative
beforehand and socially distanced on
stage
this week marked three years since the
one october shooting here in las vegas
there were tributes to the victims and
survivors all across the valley
candace bowers
[Music]
survivors joined family and friends of
those who lost their lives at the route
91 concert grounds thursday night and
also those who survived the shooting
the group started reading the names uh
behind this
concert grounds then they commemorated
each person with a picture
and a ringing of the bell survivors say
they are grateful to be part of an
amazing community
we're really grateful that we can stand
here three years later
and join together and and know that
you know out of a horrible tragedy
there was this wonderful family that was
born
and so we know that wherever we go when
we see the little decals on the cars or
the t-shirts or the hats
or whatever we know that there's family
around
also this week clark county sheriff joe
lombardo announced the official death
toll from that shooting
is now 60. two more victims died from
injury suffered in the attacks in the
last year or so
after the shooting memorials popped up
all across las vegas back in 2017
they were visible displays of sorrow
left behind by a grieving community
but those memorials couldn't stay
forever so what has happened to what was
left behind
if you were here three years ago these
aren't just memories
they're part of you little pieces of
your heart you shared or lost after las
vegas darkest night
just ran out of room so this is where
they live at the clark county museum
one october is tucked into an endless
series of boxes
ended up with some offices that weren't
in use and we needed to
turn them into storage after the
massacre
museum staff ended up with what was left
behind at memorials
more than 20 thousand artifacts cynthia
sanford is the museum's registrar
by holding onto these objects we're
telling the history of how the community
reacted
and then we were also telling individual
stories today it's all in storage
most of it the museum won't let us see
but there isn't enough room
so these climate-controlled offices hold
the rest so this is just an example
of the amount of items that were left on
each cross this time of year parts of
the archive are dusted off again
the grief is given time to breathe the
photos
of victims or friends and family those
are the hardest things to look at
because that
that really hits home that it was a
person museum staff are working on a new
larger storage facility it's one october
archive gets moved in first
until then perhaps there's comfort
knowing when las vegas poured its heart
out
it didn't just go away it reminds you of
the bad times but it also reminds you
that you know there there are people
here who who've got you back
parts of the museum's archive are now on
display at the clark county government
center downtown
the county is planning a future memorial
and that is expected to involve
more of the museum's collection the big
news for nevadans this week also
that new 250 person capacity limit on
large gatherings
and this means events could soon be
allowed at major venues that includes
games for unlv football for example at
allegion stadium
as orco mana explains strict guidelines
though will still need to be followed
today is only the first step in getting
back to our new normal
change is coming to covet 19
restrictions in nevada governor steve
sisolak increasing the group gathering
limit to 250 people or 50 percent
capacity of a venue whichever is smaller
this means we could soon see
more events across the valley we're
excited to see that
those can come back pam howitt owns
local catering company divine events
business has been slow due to the
coronavirus but she's confident the 250
person cap will
turn things around it's so great it
means we can get back
to our average number of people that we
were used to working with the 250 person
limit applies to conventions too but if
certain requirements are met up to one
thousand attendees could be allowed
this is an important first step towards
revitalizing
our hospitality industry under the
strongest social distancing and safety
guidelines in the nation
if larger venues with more than 2500
seats want to have an event they can
host up to 10 percent of their capacity
that goes for places such as allegiant
stadium and the thomas and mack center
unlv already announcing their plan for a
limited number of fans to attend
football games but additional rules must
be followed and plans must be submitted
and approved by the state
live entertainment can also return with
similar capacity limits and social
distancing las vegas performer michelle
johnson says that's music to her ears
anything is better than what we're doing
now which is missing the stage
anything's better than that i'm i try to
stay positive
and i think it's a step in the right
direction that direction
is forward if any state is going to come
back stronger
it's going to be this one orc omana 8
news now
there will also be less restrictions for
in-person religious services and open
houses
governor sysolak though says he is still
working on guidance for that moving
forward
all right so the election is about a
month away and many of you still have
questions about how it's going to work
this year in nevada
here in clark county the registrar says
1.2 million mail-in ballots are being
sent to all registered voters
the i-team's vanessa murphy has some
more information on key dates that are
useful for you
some voters in clark county may have
already received mail from
the registrar it's not the official
ballot though it should be a sample
ballot along with information about
early voting and
in-person locations for election day the
sample ballot gives voters a chance to
see it ahead of time
registrar joe gloria told the i-team
this is the longest ballot clark county
has had
starting october 7th gloria said the
official mail-in ballot would be sent
along with a postage paid return
envelope which must be postmarked by
election day november 3rd voters can
track their ballot
online or by calling the registrar's
office
early voting begins october 17th and
ends on october 30th
you can vote in person drop off your
ballot at the in-person location or
put it in the mail mail-in ballots can
be dropped off at early voting locations
and at polling places on election day
there is a seven-day period
post-election day for counties to
receive
mail and ballots as for the results
according to the nevada secretary of
state
they are unofficial until each county
certifies results
which can take up to 13 days after the
election
here's clark county registrar joe gloria
there will be no final results on
election night
we will definitely be reporting an
unofficial total
for our in-person early voting and
election day sites minus the provisional
votes
but the mail ballots will be counted for
several days after election day so our
final
unofficial won't be available to well
after election day
and a reminder voters can vote in person
or by mail due to the kovit 19 pandemic
but it's against the law
to do both vanessa murphy 8 news now
we have links where you can register to
vote or double check your information
at 8newsnow.com so every active
registered voter in clark county as
vanessa mentioned is getting sent a
ballot so
let's look at how that breaks down as of
october 1st there are 1 million 231
thousand
active registered voters 504 000 are
democrats about 350 000 in clark county
are republican
statewide over in clark county beg your
pardon about 300 000 are registered as
nonpartisan
the other groups combined for about 75
000 voters
a record number of latinos are expected
to be eligible to vote this november
our reporter kate houston tells us about
the importance in nevada of the latino
vote
the pew research center projects 32
million latinos will be eligible to vote
this election that number exceeds black
eligible voters for the first time
in nevada the research group says nearly
20 percent of eligible voters are latino
some of the key issues they'll be
focusing on tonight are the economy and
health care
i spoke to bianca balderas a political
organizer with make the road action
she says nevada saw the power of the
latino vote during the caucus
latinos have a large power to swing
a vote specifically here in nevada where
we're a minority state
we're very diverse which is very
beautiful but they also have a large
power to swing the election
latinos for trump say a key issue for
latino voters across the u.s and in
nevada
is the economy the main issue is that
for latinos is one to
how to pay the bills how to put food on
the table
how to look for the future of the for
the children and so the number one issue
without doubt is the economy the second
to that it
becomes health and health care and also
school or education he adds that safety
is another priority for latino voters
both balderas and marquez agree that
getting younger voters will be important
this election
pew research center says gen z which
ranges in age from 18 to 23
will make up one in 10 eligible voters
this november
keith houston 8 news now out of those
eligible gen z voters about 22 percent
are hispanic in nevada all right it was
a debate we're
going to remember and if you didn't
we're going to talk about it reaction
from the first presidential debate
and the rule changes that may come out
of it and also next on politics now
we're looking to look at the war of
words
in the race for congressional district
3. you're watching politics now
oh
bueno
welcome back to politics now
president donald trump and challenger
joe biden on stage for the first time
the first of three scheduled
presidential debates was earlier in the
week
the commission that puts the debates
together quickly said afterwards
they plan to make some changes to the
structure morgan writes on capitol hill
with reaction
and the first of three scheduled
presidential debates president donald
trump
and democratic nominee joe biden traded
blows and sharp criticism
listen who is rhode island senator jack
reed says biden was forced to fight back
he tried his best to maintain a much
more
professional and thoughtful approach to
the debate i thought joe biden presented
a very clear vision of what we need to
do with covet 19.
but maryland senator ben cardin says the
exchange wasn't productive you had the
president who established
the rules for this debate and then
violating those roles
president trump just does not follow
rules republican senator mitt romney
blamed the format
two minutes for each side and then open
discussion i thought
oh my goodness a major sticking point
during the debate was president trump's
apparent refusal to condemn
white supremacy stand back and stand by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about
antifa and the left i was very
disappointed when the president couldn't
decisively and unequivocally denounce
white nationalism
i think he missed republican senator tim
scott wants a better explanation i think
he should correct it if he doesn't
correct it i guess he didn't misspeak
but house minority leader kevin mccarthy
defended president trump
well how many times does he have to say
it if the question is would you denounce
it and the answer is yes
he did that the vice presidential
candidates take the stage next week
reporting in washington i'm morgan
wright
all right now let's check out some of
the spending on advertising going on in
the congressional races here in nevada
and southern nevada particularly
democratic congressman stephen horsford
has a new ad out called
helping it features nevada businesses
that received paycheck protection loans
horsford is facing republican and former
state assemblyman jim marchant for
that seat in congress now that race has
not seen the attack ads that have been
on the airwaves in congressional
district three
incumbent democratic congresswoman susie
lee has been running three different
television ads against her opponent
republican dan rodimer her six figure ad
buy
calls row dimer a hot head dangerous and
accuses of him having an
alarmingly violent rap sheet rodimer is
a former pro wrestler
and he currently owns some businesses
here in las vegas
now we have reported on those 911 calls
before here on eight news now you can
see stories about that
at eightnewsnow.com as for roe dimer he
has a new ad
himself defending himself it features
his now wife sarah rodimer
who made those calls what happened
between dan and i
was a verbal argument plain and simple
dan has never laid a hand
on me not then or ever since then the ad
as you see there has rodimer in the
background serving his family dinner
rhodeimer has run some attack ads of his
own in this campaign
he's criticized suzy lee for that ppp
loan taken by her husband's casino
company
but there has been a bit of a surprise
endorsement in this race
this week the las vegas review journal
endorsed incumbent susie lee for
congressional district 3. traditionally
the rj endorses republicans
its editorial board wrote as you see on
your screen susie lee has been a
productive
moderate voice and deserves another term
to demonstrate her devotion to
addressing washington's dysfunction
the rj also said dan rodimer would be a
strong advocate for entrepreneurs
and economic growth a fast-track
nomination coming up next on politics
now the timeline for judge amy coney
barrett's confirmation hearings for the
supreme court in the senate
and what nevada's senators are saying
about meeting with her plus
i'm alexandra limon in washington coming
up i'll tell you why it will likely be
difficult for another coronavirus relief
package to be approved
he was taken thank you
in washington supreme court nominee
judge amy coney barrett starts meeting
with senators this week
this is ahead of a fast track
confirmation process to fill the vacancy
left by the passing of justice ruth
bader ginsburg
barrett met with vice president mike
pence and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell to kick off the process
most americans are opposing a
confirmation before election day but
mcconnell says that was before the
public knew about barrett's credentials
now they have a chance to talk about a
real
flesh and blood person she's really
an exemplary person the president could
not have picked
a better nominee for this